This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难之道》，我是你们最喜欢的心理治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全展开的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，听听如何吸取
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.|||教训，就在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾多次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的规律。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.|||迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《情困》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《情困》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everyone, welcome back to a new week on the podcast. It's so great to have you here. Thanks for tuning in. Thanks for listening to this latest episode. Today we are talking about a really, really interesting topic, one that was actually suggested to me on Instagram. I put out a little poll the other day asking people, you know, kind of what they wanted to hear this week. And this response really jumped.
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everyone, welcome back to a new week on the podcast. It's so great to have you here. Thanks for tuning in. Thanks for listening to this latest episode. Today we are talking about a really, really interesting topic, one that was actually suggested to me on Instagram. I put out a little poll the other day asking people, you know, kind of what they wanted to hear this week. And this response really jumped.|||这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身以及建立恢复力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWOPOSENT”。你好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好，欢迎回到播客的新一周。很高兴你能来到这里。感谢收听。感谢收听最新一期节目。今天我们要聊一个非常非常有趣的话题，这个话题其实是有人在Instagram上向我建议的。前几天我发了一个小投票，问大家希望这周听到什么内容。而这个回答真的很引人。
out at me because I think it is a topic that isn't really spoken about in psychology that much. It's a really spiritual topic I find, but it has a lot of connections to ideas that we often talk about when we talk about social psychology and biological psychology in particular, ideas of love and attraction and partnership and connection. So I thought it would be a really interesting deep dive and I was right, the research and all the things I found out about this topic was just really magnificent and really interesting to look into. So today we are talking about the idea of a twin flame or the idea of a soulmate. Really, truly interesting. And regardless of whether you think that soulmates are really out there, whether you have one,
out at me because I think it is a topic that isn't really spoken about in psychology that much. It's a really spiritual topic I find, but it has a lot of connections to ideas that we often talk about when we talk about social psychology and biological psychology in particular, ideas of love and attraction and partnership and connection. So I thought it would be a really interesting deep dive and I was right, the research and all the things I found out about this topic was just really magnificent and really interesting to look into. So today we are talking about the idea of a twin flame or the idea of a soulmate. Really, truly interesting. And regardless of whether you think that soulmates are really out there, whether you have one,|||注目，因为我认为这是一个在心理学中并不经常被讨论的话题。我发现这是一个非常精神层面的话题，但它与我们在讨论社会心理学，尤其是生物心理学时经常谈论的许多概念有很多联系，比如爱、吸引力、伴侣关系和连接的概念。所以我认为这将是一次非常有趣的深入探讨，我猜得没错，关于这个话题的研究以及我发现的所有事情简直太棒了，深入了解起来非常有趣。所以今天我们要谈论的是双生火焰的概念，或者是灵魂伴侣的概念。真的非常有趣。不管你是否认为灵魂伴侣真的存在，不管你是否拥有一个，
whether they exist, I think some of the implications that a belief in soulmates has for our psychology and the well-being of our romantic and non-romantic relationships is something that everyone should kind of know about and a really interesting thing to think about when you approach perhaps your quest for love or how you connect with people and how you meet people. So as we always do, let's have a little intro. Let's talk a little bit about some of the background information to do with this topic. So psychology can make a lot of sense of soulmates and the term soulmates, it kind of implies this deep connection, a special affinity or an understanding, this really intense, powerful bond that exists between yourself and another person.
whether they exist, I think some of the implications that a belief in soulmates has for our psychology and the well-being of our romantic and non-romantic relationships is something that everyone should kind of know about and a really interesting thing to think about when you approach perhaps your quest for love or how you connect with people and how you meet people. So as we always do, let's have a little intro. Let's talk a little bit about some of the background information to do with this topic. So psychology can make a lot of sense of soulmates and the term soulmates, it kind of implies this deep connection, a special affinity or an understanding, this really intense, powerful bond that exists between yourself and another person.|||无论它们是否存在，我认为相信灵魂伴侣对我们的心理以及我们的浪漫和非浪漫关系的幸福感所产生的影响，是每个人都应该有所了解的事情，而且当你着手寻找爱情，或者思考你如何与他人建立连接、如何结识他人时，这是一个非常有趣值得思考的问题。所以像往常一样，我们先来做一个小小的介绍。我们来谈谈与这个话题相关的一些背景信息。心理学可以很好地解释灵魂伴侣，而“灵魂伴侣”这个词，它在某种程度上暗示了这种深厚的连接、一种特殊的亲和力或理解，这种存在于你与另一个人之间非常强烈、强大的纽带。
Historically, there have been a lot of deep beliefs and ideas, very esoteric ideas about what soulmates are. And ancient esoteric philosophy often calls soulmates our twin flames, also called our twin souls. And they believe that they are literally the other half of our soul. Your soulmate and you were once one entity, one being, one soul. And we have been separated from each other and they've been split into, and we've gone our separate ways, and we are being incarnated and brought back to life over and over again to gather human experiences before coming back together. And in some of those ancient kind of philosophical and spiritual ideas, there was this idea that, you know, we have multiple lives, we live multiple lives, we are
Historically, there have been a lot of deep beliefs and ideas, very esoteric ideas about what soulmates are. And ancient esoteric philosophy often calls soulmates our twin flames, also called our twin souls. And they believe that they are literally the other half of our soul. Your soulmate and you were once one entity, one being, one soul. And we have been separated from each other and they've been split into, and we've gone our separate ways, and we are being incarnated and brought back to life over and over again to gather human experiences before coming back together. And in some of those ancient kind of philosophical and spiritual ideas, there was this idea that, you5||| know, we have multiple lives, we live multiple lives, we are|||历史上，关于什么是灵魂伴侣，有很多深厚信仰和观念，以及非常深奥的观点。古代的神秘哲学经常把灵魂伴侣称为我们的“双生火焰”，也被称为我们的“双生灵魂”。他们认为，它们实际上是我们灵魂的另一半。你的灵魂伴侣和你曾经是一个实体、一个存在、一个灵魂。我们彼此分离，它们被一分为二，我们各走各的路，我们一次又一次地转世并复活，以收集人类的经历，然后再重新结合。在其中一些古老的哲学和精神思想中，有这样一种观点，即我们有多重生命，我们经历多重生命，我们是
reincarnated, and that person, that soulmate shows up in each one of them, and in that way we're tied together. And in many ways, some connections do really feel destined to be. It's almost like meeting this person was written in the stars and kind of heaven's aligned to make it happen. And I don't know if you felt that way. I don't even know if I felt that way. When I was researching this, I was like, dang, like this sounds brilliant. I want this. But these powerful unions in this life are kind of what we imagine to be soulmates. And a soulmate is someone that we feel that they get us.
reincarnated, and that person, that soulmate shows up in each one of them, and in that way we're tied together. And in many ways, some connections do really feel destined to be. It's almost like meeting this person was written in the stars and kind of heaven's aligned to make it happen. And I don't know if you felt that way. I don't even know if I felt that way. When I was researching this, I was like, dang, like this sounds brilliant. I want this. But these powerful unions in this life are kind of what we imagine to be soulmates. And a soulmate is someone that we feel that they get us.|||转世的，而那个人、那个灵魂伴侣会出现在每一个生命中，通过这种方式我们被联系在一起。在很多方面，某些连接确实让人感觉是命中注定的。就像与这个人的相遇是命中注定的一样，仿佛上天注定要让它发生。我不知道你是否有这种感觉。我甚至不知道我是否有这种感觉。当我研究这个的时候，我想，天哪，这听起来太棒了。我想要这个。但今生这些强有力的结合正是我们想象中的灵魂伴侣。灵魂伴侣就是那种让我们觉得他们懂我们的人。
Like we're cut from the same energetic cloth almost. And although I think the traditional notion of a soulmate or maybe your conception of a soulmate is that of a romantic partnership, as we'll talk about, they can appear in many forms. and they kind of rest upon a deep special spiritual relationship with another person. That doesn't have to be an intimate relationship. And a lot of people believe that our soulmate relationships are here to teach us something important. They hold up a mirror for us to go deeper within ourselves and to expand and evolve. And to achieve that purpose, you don't necessarily have to be romantically involved with that person.
Like we're cut from the same energetic cloth almost. And although I think the traditional notion of a soulmate or maybe your conception of a soulmate is that of a romantic partnership, as we'll talk about, they can appear in many forms. and they kind of rest upon a deep special spiritual relationship with another person. That doesn't have to be an intimate relationship. And a lot of people believe that our soulmate relationships are here to teach us something important. They hold up a mirror for us to go deeper within ourselves and to expand and evolve. And to achieve that purpose, you don't necessarily have to be romantically involved with that person.|||就像我们几乎是用同一种能量布料裁出来的一样。尽管我认为传统的灵魂伴侣概念，或者你对灵魂伴侣的理解是一段浪漫的伴侣关系，但正如我们所讨论的那样，它们可以以多种形式出现。它们在某种程度上依托于与另一个人深厚而特殊的精神关系。这不一定非得是亲密关系。许多人认为，我们的灵魂伴侣关系是为了教给我们一些重要的东西。它们为我们举起一面镜子，让我们更深入地了解自己，从而扩展和进化。为了达到这个目的，你不一定非要与那个人发生恋爱关系。
It could be a friend. It could be a teacher. we will talk all about those different theories later on. But is the idea of a soulmate or a twin flame something that can be backed up by science? I think you know the answer. It's most likely a no. But there is this wealth of kind of background information and background research that explains why we might have that feeling that someone in our lives was someone we were meant to meet. It might come from biology.
It could be a friend. It could be a teacher. we will talk all about those different theories later on. But is the idea of a soulmate or a twin flame something that can be backed up by science? I think you know the answer. It's most likely a no. But there is this wealth of kind of background information and background research that explains why we might have that feeling that someone in our lives was someone we were meant to meet. It might come from biology.|||它可以是朋友。它可以是老师。我们稍后会详细讨论所有这些不同的理论。但是，灵魂伴侣或双生火焰的想法是有科学依据的吗？我想你知道答案。答案很可能是没有。但有大量的背景信息和背景研究解释了为什么我们会有这样一种感觉：我们生活中的某个人是我们注定要遇到的人。这可能源于生物学。
it might come from attraction and from compatibility, but there are certain reactions that come from our interactions with others that make us more in tune with someone else, and that's something I really want to discuss. And there are also some darker sides to believing that we have one person out there for us. So a lot of really interesting things we're talking about today. Let's dive right in. Okay, so perhaps the first thing we should talk about is how do we
it might come from attraction and from compatibility, but there are certain reactions that come from our interactions with others that make us more in tune with someone else, and that's something I really want to discuss. And there are also some darker sides to believing that we have one person out there for us. So a lot of really interesting things we're talking about today. Let's dive right in. Okay, so perhaps the first thing we should talk about is how do we|||它可能源于吸引力和契合度，但我们在与他人互动时会产生某些反应，这些反应使我们与某个人更加同频，这是我非常想讨论的。而且，相信世界上有一个专属于自己的人，这也存在一些阴暗面。所以今天我们要谈论很多非常有趣的事情。让我们直接切入正题吧。好的，也许我们首先应该讨论的是，我们如何
know if we've maybe met a soulmate? Maybe you have someone in your life right now who you think is your twin flame. You think they are your other half, your better half. And how are we able to discern that that person is really kind of divinely meant to be with us or whether we just have a strong alignment with them? How do we know that, you know, maybe someone we've met might be one of our soulmates might be one of those deep, meaningful connections we hold with us. for our entire life. Well, here are some of those indicators or characteristics of a relationship that might indicate that the person you're connecting to might be someone who you could connect to deeper or who is
know if we've maybe met a soulmate? Maybe you have someone in your life right now who you think is your twin flame. You think they are your other half, your better half. And how are we able to discern that that person is really kind of divinely meant to be with us or whether we just have a strong alignment with them? How do we know that, you know, maybe someone we've met might be one of our soulmates might be one of those deep, meaningful connections we hold with us. for our entire life. Well, here are some of those indicators or characteristics of a relationship that might indicate that the person you're connecting to might be someone who you could connect to deeper or who is|||知道自己是否可能已经遇到了灵魂伴侣？也许你现在生命中就有这样一个人，你认为他是你的双生火焰。你认为他们是你的另一半，你更好的半个。我们如何能够辨别这个人真的是上天注定要和我们在一起的，还是我们只是与他们有着高度的契合？我们怎么知道，你知道，也许我们遇到的人可能是我们的灵魂伴侣，可能是我们一生中保持的那种深厚而有意义的连接之一。好吧，以下是关系中的一些指标或特征，它们可能表明你正在连接的人可能是你可以与之建立更深层连接的人，或者是
potentially a soulmate. So you might feel a connection with them almost instantly and on an intuitive level. Intuition is not just kind of a mystical, spiritual idea. It's a legitimate scientific concept that has a lot of evidence. supporting its legitimacy and its existence. In psychology, the idea of intuition, it's defined as kind of the productive influence of unconscious emotional information. So intuition is kind of like a brain process that gives us the ability to make decisions
potentially a soulmate. So you might feel a connection with them almost instantly and on an intuitive level. Intuition is not just kind of a mystical, spiritual idea. It's a legitimate scientific concept that has a lot of evidence. supporting its legitimacy and its existence. In psychology, the idea of intuition, it's defined as kind of the productive influence of unconscious emotional information. So intuition is kind of like a brain process that gives us the ability to make decisions|||潜在的灵魂伴侣。因此，你几乎可以瞬间在直觉层面上感受到与他们的连接。直觉不仅仅是一种神秘的精神概念。这是一个合法的科学概念，有大量的证据支持其合法性和存在性。在心理学中，直觉的概念被定义为无意识情感信息的生产性影响。所以直觉有点像大脑的一个过程，它赋予我们做出决定的能力
without the use of analytical reasoning. It's almost the activity of the old brain, of this unconscious thought process that is constantly going on in our minds, that allows us to make decisions without needing to think about them every single second. And it applies when we meet someone and we are unconsciously able to recognize something unique about that person that somehow aligns with us, even if that thought is not happening on a conscious higher up level. We're going to talk about personality compatibility later on in this episode. But intuition and recognizing something similar in someone else almost instantly
without the use of analytical reasoning. It's almost the activity of the old brain, of this unconscious thought process that is constantly going on in our minds, that allows us to make decisions without needing to think about them every single second. And it applies when we meet someone and we are unconsciously able to recognize something unique about that person that somehow aligns with us, even if that thought is not happening on a conscious higher up level. We're going to talk about personality compatibility later on in this episode. But intuition and recognizing something similar in someone else almost instantly|||无需使用分析推理。这几乎是古老大脑的活动，是我们脑海中不断进行的这种无意识思维过程，它让我们无需每时每刻都在思考就能做出决定。当我们遇到某人并且能够在无意识中认出那个人身上某种与我们契合的独特之处时，这种情况就会适用，即使这种想法并没有发生在有意识的高级层面上。我们将在本集的后面讨论性格契合度。但直觉和几乎瞬间认出别人身上相似的东西
is a core part of why you might feel a deep connection with someone. There are some other indicators as well that you may have met a soulmate or someone you are destined to meet. You might feel a really strong chemistry upon meeting them, an intense energy, an intense connection. You feel understood because of the strength of the bond that you have between that person and yourself. And isn't that just an amazing feeling?
is a core part of why you might feel a deep connection with someone. There are some other indicators as well that you may have met a soulmate or someone you are destined to meet. You might feel a really strong chemistry upon meeting them, an intense energy, an intense connection. You feel understood because of the strength of the bond that you have between that person and yourself. And isn't that just an amazing feeling?|||是你可能与某人产生深厚连接的核心部分。还有一些其他指标表明你可能遇到了灵魂伴侣或你注定要遇到的人。初次见面时，你可能会感受到非常强烈的化学反应、强烈的能量、强烈的连接。由于你与那个人之间纽带的强度，你会感到被理解。这难道不是一种奇妙的感觉吗？
Feeling understood, feeling seen. Critically, you accept them at their best. and they do the same for you. I want to talk about that a little bit later on. I think I have the saying that love is forgiveness. And I think that idea of accepting people for their floors is really indicative that you've met someone who you have a really deep connection with.
Feeling understood, feeling seen. Critically, you accept them at their best. and they do the same for you. I want to talk about that a little bit later on. I think I have the saying that love is forgiveness. And I think that idea of accepting people for their floors is really indicative that you've met someone who you have a really deep connection with.|||感到被理解，感到被看见。关键是，你接受他们最好的一面。他们也为你这样做。我稍后想谈谈这一点。我想我有一句名言：爱就是宽容。我认为那种接受人们缺点的想法确实表明你遇到了一个与你有着非常深厚连接的人。
You might recognize them. So this sounds really wishy-washy, maybe a little bit bizarre, but I'm trying to put everything on the table. When I say recognize them, I mean, like you might physically be like, that person seems familiar. And some people might say that, you know, you knew them in a past life and therefore
You might recognize them. So this sounds really wishy-washy, maybe a little bit bizarre, but I'm trying to put everything on the table. When I say recognize them, I mean, like you might physically be like, that person seems familiar. And some people might say that, you know, you knew them in a past life and therefore|||你可能会认出他们。这听起来可能非常模棱两可，甚至有点怪异，但我试图把所有事情都摆上台面。当我大声说出“认出他们”时，我的意思是，从身体上你可能会觉得，那个人看起来很面熟。有些人可能会说，你知道，你在前世就认识他们，因此
recognize them and that there is some form of bond that traverses space and time. In terms of scientific evidence for this, there isn't much. But I do think we've perhaps all maybe felt that way about someone else. So even anecdotally, we may read something into the fact that we can sometimes recognize people that we see as soulmates and they feel familiar to us, like we've known them before. You also have deep empathy towards one another. Empathy is a crucial factor in most really close relationship, so it makes sense that it turns up when we're discussing twin flames.
recognize them and that there is some form of bond that traverses space and time. In terms of scientific evidence for this, there isn't much. But I do think we've perhaps all maybe felt that way about someone else. So even anecdotally, we may read something into the fact that we can sometimes recognize people that we see as soulmates and they feel familiar to us, like we've known them people before. You also have deep empathy towards one another. Empathy is a crucial factor in most really close relationship, so it makes sense that it turns up when we're discussing twin flames.|||认出了他们，并且存在某种跨越时空的纽带。就这方面的科学证据而言，并没有多少。但我确实认为我们可能都对其他人有过这种感觉。因此，甚至从轶事来看，我们有时会从这样一个事实中解读出一些东西：我们有时能够认出我们视为灵魂伴侣的人，他们让我们感到熟悉，就像我们以前认识他们一样。你们对彼此也有着深厚的同理心。同理心是大多数真正亲密关系中的关键因素，所以在我们讨论双生火焰时出现同理心是合情合理的。
This was a really interesting one. I saw this on a website, and I really related to this. You don't always need to speak to be able to connect. I don't know if you've had that experience where you're sitting in silence with someone and it feels comfortable, even enjoyable. And you don't feel the need to feel that. silence constantly. You can still connect and communicate without talking or communicating verbally. But when you do choose to communicate, it's honest, it's vulnerable. And your values align.
This was a really interesting one. I saw this on a website, and I really related to this. You don't always need to speak to be able to connect. I don't know if you've have that experience where you're sitting in silence with someone and it feels comfortable, even enjoyable. And you don't feel the need to feel that. silence constantly. You can still connect and communicate without talking or communicating verbally. But when you do choose to communicate, it's honest, it's vulnerable. And your values align.|||这是一个非常有趣的现象。我在一个网站上看到了这个，我对此深有感触。你并不总是需要说话才能建立连接。我不知道你是否有过这样的经历：你和某人默默地坐在一起，感觉很舒服，甚至很享受。你并不觉得有必要一直打破这种沉默。即使不说话或不用言语交流，你仍然可以建立连接和交流。但当你确实选择交流时，它是诚实的、脆弱的。而且你们的价值观是一致的。
Underneath that deep twin flame, passionate connection are deeper values that connect you to someone. I think this makes a lot of sense. It's really difficult to have a really deep relationship with someone who fundamentally you don't agree on the same things. Fundamentally, you have different values and attitudes towards respect for others towards what a good life means about what you want out of life. What's important? Another indicator you may have met your twin flame or your soulmate is that you can let your guard down and things feel easy. It's not strained or it's not difficult. My friend Kate always says this. Love should be easy and you can be vulnerable with that person without fear, without feeling like there's judgment, that you're saying the wrong things, that you're
Underneath that deep twin flame, passionate connection are deeper values that connect you to someone. I think this makes a lot of sense. It's really difficult to have a really deep relationship with someone who fundamentally you don't agree on the same things. Fundamentally, you have different values and attitudes towards respect for others towards what a good life means about what you want out of life. What's important? Another indicator you may have met your twin flame or your soulmate is that you can let your guard down and things feel easy. It's not strained or it's not difficult. My friend Kate always says this. Love should be easy and you can be vulnerable with that person without fear, without feeling like there's judgment, that you're saying the wrong things, that you're|||在这种深厚的双生火焰、热烈的连接之下，是将你与某人联系在一起的更深层的价值观。我认为这很有道理。如果你和某人在根本问题上无法达成一致，那么要建立真正的深厚关系是非常困难的。从根本上讲，你们对尊重他人、对美好生活的意义、对你们想从生活中得到什么有着不同的价值观和态度。什么才是最重要的？你可能遇到双生火焰或灵魂伴侣的另一个迹象是，你可以放下防备，一切都感觉很轻松。没有紧张感，也没有困难。我的朋友凯特总是这么说。爱应该是轻松的，你可以对那个人展现脆弱而毫无畏惧，不会觉得有评判，不会觉得自己说错了话，不会觉得自己
not able to speak your truth. And this person supports your growth. Soulmates don't enter our lives just to bring excitement and fun and love and good times. This kind of soul contract, as some people call it, is ultimately about deeper things. That means your soulmate in whatever form they arrive will actively support your growth and development as a person. They will encourage you, they lift you up, they offer you practical help so you can reach your goals. But sometimes this can include hard truths. Like we've previously mentioned, twin flames or soulmates, they might just be there to really hold up a mirror so you can observe yourself. And in that reflection, you might not only see good things. You might see some of those elements of yourself that
not able to speak your truth. And this person supports your growth. Soulmates don't enter our lives just to bring excitement and fun and love and good times. This kind of soul contract, as some people call it, is ultimately about deeper things. That means your soulmate in whatever form they arrive will actively support your growth and development as a person. They will encourage you, they lift you up, they offer you practical help so you can reach your goals. But sometimes this can include hard truths. Like we've previously mentioned, twin flames or soulmates, they might just be there to really hold up a mirror so you can observe yourself. And in that reflection, you might not only see good things. You might see some of those elements of yourself that|||无法说出真相。而且这个人支持你的成长。灵魂伴侣进入我们的生活不仅仅是为了带来刺激、乐趣、爱和美好的时光。正如有些人所说，这种灵魂契约归根结底关乎更深层次的事情。这意味着你的灵魂伴侣无论以何种形式出现，都会积极支持你作为个人的成长和发展。他们会鼓励你，振奋你，为你提供实际的帮助，以便你实现目标。但有时这可能包括严酷的真相。正如我们前面提到的，双生火焰或灵魂伴侣，他们可能只是在那里真正举起一面镜子，以便你观察自己。在那面镜子里，你可能不仅会看到美好的事物。你可能会看到自己身上的一些元素
you want to work towards and improve. And I think that is part of this greater idea of soulmates. It doesn't need to be unconditional, but this love that you might have for this other person and then for you is about growing and it's about learning lessons and building a deeper understanding of yourself and your values. We're going to talk about different types of soulmates now. As I'm sure you've kind of gathered, I don't think that they're purely romantic. And I do believe in the idea of soulmates or twin flames. And I'm really stressing that plural form there. I don't see our soulmate as being one person,
you want to work towards and improve. And I think that is part of this greater idea of soulmates. It doesn't need to be unconditional, but this love that you might have for this other person and then for you is about growing and it's about learning lessons and building a deeper understanding of yourself and your values. We're going to talk about different types of soulmates now. As I'm sure you've kind of gathered, I don't think that they're purely romantic. And I do believe in the idea of soulmates or twin flames. And I'm really stressing that plural form there. I don't see our soulmate as being one person,|||你想要努力和改进的地方。我认为这是灵魂伴侣这个伟大理念的一部分。它不需要是无条件的你对另一个人以及对你自己的这种爱，是关于成长的，是关于吸取教训并对你自己和你的价值观建立更深理解的。我们现在来谈谈不同类型的灵魂伴侣。正如我确信你已经体会到的那样，我不认为它们纯粹是浪漫的。而且我确实相信灵魂伴侣或双生火焰的概念。我在这里着重强调了复数形式。我不认为我们的灵魂伴侣只有一个人，
like that traditional religious version of the idea is, you know, that you are once one entity and now you're two, very Adam and Eve kind of mythology there. My belief is that there are many people that we are meant to meet and that we are meant to connect to. and they don't always have to be in our life forever and they don't always have to be romantic. I have friends who are soulmates to me who are people that like I said with kind of tick those boxes across all of those indicators of supporting my growth, of holding me accountable, being able to
like that traditional religious version of the idea is, you know, that you are once one entity and now you're two, very Adam and Eve kind of mythology there. My belief is that there are many people that we are meant to meet and that we are meant to connect to. and they don't always have to be in our life forever and they don't always have to be romantic. I have friends who are soulmates to me who are people that like I said with kind of tick those boxes across all of those indicators of supporting my growth, of holding me accountable, being able to|||就像传统的宗教版本的概念一样，你知道，就是你曾经是一个实体，现在你是两个，那里有非常亚当和夏娃式的神话。我的信念是，有许多人是我们注定要遇见的，也是我们注定要建立连接的。他们不一定永远留在我们的生活中，也不一定总是浪漫的。我有些朋友是我的灵魂伴侣，他们就像我刚才说的，在支持我的成长、对我负责、能够
sit in silence. And sometimes they're not even people that you know for longer than a moment, but the idea of a soulmate is someone that you feel divinely connected to who comes into your life and teaches you something and who feels familiar. So romantic soulmates are obviously what we think of when we hear the term twin flame. Often you might hear people call their partner their soulmate. They're someone who brings them passionate, intellectual, emotional and spiritual, physical experiences. And that sounds amazing, right? That sounds fantastic. And if you've met someone you connect with like that, the magic of these sensations can make us feel like the love we share with that person was meant to be,
sit in silence. And sometimes they're not even people that you know for longer than a moment, but the idea of a soulmate is someone that you feel divinely connected to who comes into your life and teaches you something and who feels familiar. So romantic soulmates are obviously what we think of when we hear the term twin flame. Often you might hear people call their partner their soulmate. They're someone who brings them passionate, intellectual, emotional and spiritual, physical experiences. And that sounds amazing, right? That sounds fantastic. And if you've met someone you connect with like that, the magic of these sensations can make us feel like the love we share with that person was meant to be,|||静静相处等所有这些指标上都符合要求。有时他们甚至不是你认识超过一瞬间的人，但灵魂伴侣的概念是，你觉得与他有着神圣连接、走进你的生活并教给你某些东西、而且让你觉得熟悉的人.所以当我们听到“双生火焰”这个词时，浪漫的灵魂伴侣显然是我们首先想到的。通常你可能会听到人们称他们的伴侣为他们的灵魂伴侣。他们是带给他们激情、智力、情感和精神、身体体验的人。这听起来太棒了，对吧？听起来棒极了。如果你遇到了一个与你有这种连接的人，这些感觉的魔力会让我们觉得我们与那个人分享的爱是命中注定的，
that it has divine purpose, divine timing. And interestingly, this idea of a soulmate, it does appear in a lot of cultures. So the Yiddish word for soulmate is Bashred. And it's the belief that before birth, God decided your spouse, and they are a match made in heaven. So the idea is that even before you were born, God kind of decided who would be your partner, and they're the person that you ultimately meet in your life. I don't know how much I believe that, but it's interesting that it's shown up throughout history. And it's also kind of found in other parts of the world and in other timeframes, although it might have some different names. So this is a theory, well, not really a theory, but almost folklore. And it comes out of East Asia, and I was obsessed with this
that it has divine purpose, divine timing. And interestingly, this idea of a soulmate, it does appear in a lot of cultures. So the Yiddish word for soulmate is Bashred. And it's the belief that before birth, God decided your spouse, and they are a match made in heaven. So the idea is that even before you were born, God kind of decided who would be your partner, and they're the person that you ultimately meet in your life. I don't how much I believe that, but it's interesting that it's shown up throughout history. And it's also kind of found in other parts of the other world and in other timeframes, although it might have some different names. So this is a theory, well, not really a theory, but almost folklore. And it comes out of East Asia, and I was obsessed with this|||它具有神圣的目的、神圣的时机。有趣的是，“灵魂伴侣”这个概念确实出现在许多文化中。因此，意第绪语中灵魂伴侣的词是 Bashred。人们相信，在出生之前，上帝就决定了你的配偶，他们是天作之合。所以这个想法是，甚至在你出生之前，上帝就已经决定了谁会成为你的伴侣，而他们就是你在生活中最终遇到的人。我不知道我有多相信这一点，但有趣的是它贯穿了整个历史。在世界的其他地方和其他时期也可以找到它，尽管它可能有不同的名字。所以这是一个理论，嗯，不是真正的理论，但几乎是民间传说。它发源于东亚，我曾经对此痴迷
when I was younger. I believed in this wholeheartedly. And it's called the red thread of fate. And originally, it originated from Chinese mythology, but it's also found throughout, like a said, of a lot of East Asian cultures, such as Japanese culture. And the kind of myth or the legend is that it's kind of thought as that there is an invisible red cord around the finger of those who are destined to meet another in any in their lifetime and it's the idea of true love that this red string this red thread connects you and according to chinese legend the deity in charge of the red thread is believed to be this person called yulau and they are the old lunar matchmaker god who is in charge of marriages so these two people connected by this red thread are destined lovers
when I was younger. I believed in this wholeheartedly. And it's called the red thread of fate. And originally, it originated from Chinese mythology, but it's also found throughout, like a said, of a lot of East Asian cultures, such as Japanese culture. And the kind of myth or the legend is that it's kind of thought as that there is an invisible red cord around the finger of those who are destined to meet another in any in their lifetime and it's the idea of true love that this red string this red thread connects you and according to chinese legend the deity in charge of the red thread is believed to be this person called yulau and they are the old lunar matchmaker god who is in charge of marriages so these two people connected by this red thread are destined lovers|||当我年轻的时候。我对此深信不疑。它被称为命运的红线。最初，它起源于中国神话，但正如我所说，它也存在于许多东亚文化中，例如日本文化。这种神话或传说的意思是，人们认为在任何一生中注定要相遇的人的手指上都有一根看不见的红绳，这就是真爱的理念，这根红绳、这根红线将你们连接在一起，根据中国传说，掌管红线的神明被认为是这个叫月老的人，他们是掌管婚姻的月下老人。所以这两个被红线连接的人是命中注定的恋人
regardless of place, time, circumstances, this magical chord, the idea goes, it might stretch, it might tangle, but it never breaks. And this myth is very similar to this Western concept of a soulmate or a destined partner. And these kind of notions or folk stories and ideas of a soulmate are beautiful. And maybe you have imagined what it would be like to love and connect with someone that deeply. But when we analyze the idea of a soulmate in the romantic sense from a psychological rather than a spiritual perspective, it can become complicated and it has a lot less to do with this mystical worldly divine intervention. So research has highlighted a potentially darker side to believing in soulmates when we aren't able to learn or manage our expectations. So even a match made in
regardless of place, time, circumstances, this magical chord, the idea goes, it might stretch, it might tangle, but it never breaks. And this myth is very similar to this Western concept of a soulmate or a destined partner. And these kind of notions or folk stories and ideas of a soulmate are beautiful. And maybe you have imagined what it would be like to love and connection with someone that deeply. But when we analyze the idea of a soulmate in the romantic sense from a psychological rather than a spiritual perspective, it can become complicated and it has a lot less to do with this mystical worldly divine intervention. So research has highlighted a potentially darker side to believing in soulmates when we aren't able to learn or manage our expectations. So even a match made in|||无论地点、时间、环境如何，这个魔法般的琴弦，这个概念认为，它可能会拉伸，可能会缠绕，但永远不会断裂。这个神话与西方关于灵魂伴侣或命中注定的伴侣的概念非常相似。这些关于灵魂伴侣的观念、民间故事和想法是美丽的。也许你曾想象过与某人如此深沉地相爱和连接会是什么样子。但是，当我们从心理学而不是精神的角度来分析浪漫意义上的灵魂伴侣的概念时，它就会变得复杂，并且与这种神秘的世俗神圣干预没有太大关系。因此，研究强调了相信灵魂伴侣潜在的阴暗面，即当我们无法学习或管理我们的期望时。所以即使是天作之合
heaven will always experience conflict. And according to this really interesting study done by this author called Lee, believing that a soulmate relationship is somehow a finished product, something that you find and that requires no work, is really detrimental. This author did a bit of further research on this. He says that there are two perspectives we can take when it comes to romantic relationships and the idea that out there exists our twin flame. Researchers into this belief and to this kind of divine love identify two types of thinkers when it comes to soulmates. We can call them non-believers and believers, but they call them destiny believers and growth believers. So a destiny believer, they have these passionate,
heaven will always experience conflict. And according to this really interesting study done by this author called Lee, believing that a soulmate relationship is somehow a finished product, something that you find and that requires no work, is really detrimental. This author did a bit of further research on this. He says that there are two perspectives we can take when it comes to romantic relationships and the idea that out there exists our twin flame. Researchers into this belief and to this kind of divine love identify two types of thinkers when it comes to soulmates. We can call them non-believers and believers, but they call them destiny believers and growth believers. So a destiny believer, they have these passionate,|||也总是会经历冲突。根据一位名叫李的作者所做的一项非常有趣的研究，认为灵魂伴侣关系某种程度上是一个成品，是你找到的、不需要付出任何努力的东西，这是非常有害的。这位作者对此进行了一些进一步的研究。他说，在谈到浪漫关系以及世界上存在我们的双生火焰这一观点时，我们可以采取两种视角。对这种信仰和这种神圣之爱进行研究的研究人员在谈到灵魂伴侣时确定了两种类型的思考者。我们可以称他们为不信者和信者，但他们称之为命运论信徒和成长论信徒。所以命运论信徒，他们拥有这些充满激情、
intense, fiery short-term relationships. And they often think of love as something that comes to you and something that is meant to be, something that is effortless and easy and beautiful and fully constructed upon arrival. Whereas growth believers, they might take a little bit longer to commit. They kind of believe that love is something that requires work and effort, that there might not be one perfect person out there for you, but many people who you could find yourself being really happy with. Growth believers within a relationship often lead to more successful long-term partnerships compared to so-called destiny believers because they believe that issues and problems and incompatibilities which will always emerge can be fixed and worked through. So essentially,
intense, fiery short-term relationships. And they often think of love as something that comes to you and something that is meant to be, something that is effortless and easy and beautiful and fully constructed upon arrival. Whereas growth believers, they might take a little bit longer to commit. They kind of believe that love is something that requires work and effort, that there might not be one perfect person out there for you, but many people who you could find yourself being really happy with. Growth believers within a relationship often lead to more successful long-term partnerships compared to so-called destiny believers because they believe that issues and problems and incompatibilities which will always emerge can be fixed and worked through. So essentially,|||强烈而炽热的短期关系。他们通常认为爱是降临在你身上并且命中注定的东西，是不费力气、轻松美丽且一到来就完全构建好的东西。而成长论信徒，他们可能需要更长的时间来作出承诺。他们倾向于认为爱是需要工作和努力的东西，世界上可能没有一个完美的人在等你，但有许多人能让你感到真正的幸福。与所谓的命运论信徒相比，关系中的成长论信徒往往能带来更成功的长期伴侣关系，因为他们相信必然会出现的问题、矛盾和不契合是可以修复和解决的。所以本质上，
this researcher found that those people who believe in soulmates really deeply are are more likely to break up, give up or have difficult relationships if their beliefs create a fixed attitude within that partnership. So an unhealthy idea that soulmate union should be perfect, perfect may lead us to have, like I said, these passionate and intense short-term relationships, disillusionment and frustration over challenges. You might impose deal breakers or unfair demands on your partner because you have this specific idea of who your soulmate is.
this researcher found that those people who believe in soulmates really deeply are are more likely to break up, give up or have difficult relationships if their beliefs create a fixed attitude within that partnership. So an unhealthy idea that soulmate union should be perfect, perfect may lead us to have, like I said, these passionate and intense short-term relationships, disillusionment and frustration over challenges. You might impose deal breakers or unfair demands on your partner because you have this specific idea of who your soulmate is.|||这位研究人员发现，那些深信灵魂伴侣的人，如果他们的信念在这种伴侣关系中产生了固定的态度，反而更有可能分手、放弃或拥有艰难的关系。因此，那种认为灵魂伴侣的结合应该是完美的、绝对完美的不健康想法，可能会导致我们拥有正如我所说的那样充满激情和强烈的短期关系，以及面对挑战时的幻想破灭和挫折感。你可能会对你的伴侣强加破坏关系的底线或不公平的要求，因为你对你的灵魂伴侣是谁有着这种具体的想法。
You might also believe that love should be instant, that all love is founded on instantaneous attraction and energy, when in reality it might actually take time to build. And like I said before, it might result in you moving on rather than trying to fix your relationship problems if you're of the belief that there is one person, one perfect person who is out there for you. On the other hand, people who have a growth attitude towards relationships tend to take longer to commit, but they stay longer. And they look to find solutions and compromises in their relationship and believe that relationships take effort and you grow to fit each other. You grow to
You might also believe that love should be instant, that all love is founded on instantaneous attraction and energy, when in reality it might actually take time to build. And like I said before, it might result in you moving on rather than trying to fix your relationship problems if you're of the belief that there is one person, one perfect person who is out there for you. On the other hand, people who have a growth attitude towards relationships tend to take longer to commit, but they stay longer. And they look to find solutions and compromises in their relationship and believe that relationships take effort and you grow to fit each other. You grow to|||你还可能认为爱应该是瞬息即逝的，所有的爱都建立在瞬间的吸引力和能量之上，而实际上它可能确实需要时间来建立。正如我之前所说，如果你坚信外面有一个人、一个完美的人是为你而存在的，这可能会导致你选择离开，而不是去试图修复你的感情问题。另一方面，对感情持成长态度的人往往需要更长的时间来作出承诺，但他们停留的时间更长。他们试图在他们的关系中寻找解决方案和妥协，并相信关系需要努力，而且你们在成长中相互适应。你们在成长中
fit together. And they believe that love is built. So regardless of whether there is actually a perfect person out there for us, and obviously that's up for debate, it is the very belief in the idea of a soulmate that actually might be most influential on whether, we find love and the types of connections we build with some people and whether that initial energy and chemistry we feel with someone can be built into something that is trusting and stable and long term. Those are some of those I some of the ideas around romantic soulmates how we traditionally think of our twin flame but like I mentioned I don't think that they always have to do with intimacy that these people we are meant to meet are always going to be lovers or people that we connect with
fit together. And they believe that love is built. So regardless of whether there is actually a perfect person out there for us, and obviously that's up for debate, it is the very belief in the idea of a soulmate that actually might be most influential on whether, we find love and the types of connections we build with some people and whether that initial energy and chemistry we feel with someone can be built into something that is trusting and stable and long term. Those are some of those I some of the ideas around romantic soulmates how we traditionally think of our twin flame but like I mentioned, I don't think that they always have to do with intimacy that these people we are meant to meet are always going to be lovers or people that we connect with|||彼此契合。他们相信爱是构建出来的。因此，无论世界上是否真的有一个完美的人在等着我们，这显然还有待商榷，但对灵魂伴侣这一概念的信念本身，实际上才最能影响我们是否能找到爱、我们与某些人建立的连接类型，以及我们与某人感受到的最初能量和化学反应是否能被构建成一种充满信任、稳定且长期的东西。这些是我对浪漫灵魂伴侣的一些看法，即我们传统上如何看待我们的双生火焰，但正如我提到的，我不认为它们总是与亲密关系有关，即我们注定要遇到的人总是情人或我们与之建立连接的人
on a physical level. Friendship soulmates are just as valid. Friends are an essential part of our journey and these types of soulmates are those that help us laugh when we're in pain, they nurture us, they flow with us when we're riding high, they challenge us to be real and to be vulnerable and to speak our truth and they love us despite our problems and our flaws. and we love them for that as well. These people are not those that we are necessarily attracted to or have a sexual relationship with, but they are so critical for our well-being
on a physical level. Friendship soulmates are just as valid. Friends are an essential part of our journey and these types of soulmates are those that help us laugh when we're in pain, they nurture us, they flow with us when we're riding high, they challenge us to be real and to be vulnerable and to speak our truth and they love us despite our problems and our flaws. and we love them for that as well. These people are not those that we are necessarily attracted to or have a sexual relationship with, but they are so critical for our well-being|||在身体层面上。友谊灵魂伴侣同样有效。朋友是我们人生旅程中不可或缺的一部分，这类灵魂伴侣会在我们痛苦时逗我们笑，滋养我们，在我们春风得意时与我们一同随性，他们挑战我们去做真实的自己、展露脆弱、说出真相，他们爱我们，包容我们的问题和缺陷。我们也因此而爱他们。这些人不一定是我们会被其吸引或与之发生性关系的人，但他们对我们的幸福至关重要
and our sense of belonging and love. And I think with traditional notions of partnership, when you have your partner, when you've met your match, if you're a monogamous person, you really only have room for one. But the idea of friendship soulmates means that you have opportunities to have multiple of these people. and I feel very blessed to have been able to meet some of people like this in my life and they continue to be in my life.
and our sense of belonging and love. And I think with traditional notions of partnership, when you have your partner, when you've met your match, if you're a monogamous person, you really only have room for one. But the idea of friendship soulmates means that you have opportunities to have multiple of these people. and I feel very blessed to have been able to meet some of people like this in my life and they continue to be in my life.|||以及我们的归属感和爱。我认为根据传统的伴侣观念，当你有了伴侣，当你遇到了你的绝配，如果你是一个实行一夫一妻制的人，你的心中其实真的只能容纳一个人。但友谊灵魂伴侣的概念意味着你有机会拥有多个这样的人。我感到非常幸运，能够在我的生命中遇到这样的一些人，而且他们现在依然在我的生活中。
I specifically remember meeting my best friend Zoe and when I think about those characteristics or indicators of when you've met a soulmate, they all seem to apply. It was our first day of high school and I saw this girl sitting out the front of our school and she was crying. I hope she doesn't mind me saying this, but she was really upset. And I saw her and I was like, I don't know what it was, I was like, I'm going to be friends with that person. I recognize her. There's something about her. That instant chemistry. And I went up to her and I started talking to her. And ever since then, we have been so close, thick as thieves. It's like she knows me better than I know myself. And it doesn't necessarily mean that her love is unconditional. I think the reason why I see her as a
I specifically remember meeting my best friend Zoe and when I think about those characteristics or indicators of when you've met a soulmate, they all seem to apply. It was our first day of high school and I saw this girl sitting out the front of our school and she was crying. I hope she doesn't mind me saying this, but she was really upset. And I saw her and I was like, I don't know what it was, I was like, I'm going to be friends with that person. I recognize her. There's something about her. That instant chemistry. And I went up to her and I started talking to her. And ever since then, we have been so close, thick as thieves. It's like she knows me better than I know myself. And it doesn't necessarily mean that her love is unconditional. I think the reason why I see her as a|||我特别记得遇到我最好的朋友佐伊的那一天，当我回想那些当你遇到灵魂伴侣时的特征或指标时，它们似乎都适用。那是我们上高中的第一天，我看到这个女孩坐在我们学校门前，她哭了。我希望她不介意我这么说，但她真的很沮丧。我看到她时，我想，我不知道是什么原因，我当时就想，我要和那个人交朋友。我认出她了。她身上有一种特质。那种瞬间的化学反应。我朝她走去，开始和她聊天。从那以后，我们一直非常亲密，形影不离。就好像她比我自己更了解我。这并不一定意味着她的爱是无条件的。我想我之所以视她为
soulmate and why we are so close. And I've said this to her so many times is that she also sees and knows my bad qualities. She knows the worst things about me and still loves me and can look past them and has this idea of me that is not delusional and is forgiving and it acknowledges me for who I truly am on a deep level and I hope that I do the same for her. So I hope that emphasises the importance of friendships as soulmates and friends as twin flames because sometimes that's who they are. There are a couple other ideas. I think maybe the traditional way to go about this would be to talk about friends. and to talk about romance. But I found this concept that I thought was really interesting. Two concepts, actually.
soulmate and why we are so close. And I've said this to her so many times is that she also sees and knows my bad qualities. She knows the worst things about me and still loves me and can look past them and has this idea of me that is not delusional and is forgiving and it acknowledges me for who I truly am on a deep level and I hope that I do the same for her. So I hope that emphasises the importance of friendships as soulmates and friends as twin flames because sometimes that's who they are. There are a couple other ideas. I think maybe the traditional way to go about this would be to talk about friends.|||灵魂伴侣以及我们如此亲密的原因，而且我对她说过很多次，是因为她也能看到并了解我的缺点。她知道我最糟糕的事情，却依然爱我，能够忽略这些缺点，对我的看法并不带有幻想而是充满宽容，并且在深层次上认可真正的我，我也希望我对她也是如此。所以我希望这能强调友谊作为灵魂伴侣和朋友作为双生火焰的重要性，因为有时他们就是这样的人。还有其他几个想法。我想也许传统的做法是谈论朋友。
Firstly, it's the idea that we have teacher soulmates in life, not just romantic and friends, and not just romantic soulmates and friendship soulmates, but teacher soulmates. And to a certain extent, we learn from all people in one way or another, but especially with our teacher twin flames. They might be a valued mentor or healer in your life
and to talk about romance. But I found this concept that I thought was really interesting. Two concepts, actually. Firstly, it's the idea that we have teacher soulmates in life, not just romantic and friends, and not just romantic soulmates and friendship soulmates, but teacher soulmates. And to a certain extent, we learn from all people in one way or another, but especially with our teacher twin flames. They might be a valued mentor or healer in your life|||并谈论浪漫。但我发现了这个我认为非常有趣的概念。实际上是两个概念。首先，这种观点认为我们在生活中拥有导师灵魂伴侣，不仅仅是浪漫和朋友，不仅仅是浪漫的灵魂伴侣和友谊的灵魂伴侣，还有导师灵魂伴侣。在某种程度上，我们以这样或那样的方式向所有人学习，尤其是向我们的导师双生火焰学习。他们可能是你生命中一位备受尊崇的导师或治愈者
who you meet with divine timing. They could be an inspirational, you know, professor from school who encourages you to pursue something new, thinking about the Dead Poets Society, I don't know why. And, you know, there could even be a total stranger who has really wise words for you.
who you meet with divine timing. They could be an inspirational, you know, professor from school who encourages you to pursue something new, thinking about the Dead Poets Society, I don't know why. And, you know, there could even be a total stranger who has really wise words for you.|||你以神圣的时机与他们相遇。他们可能是学校里一位鼓舞人心的教授，鼓励你追求新事物，我想到了《死亡诗社》，不知道为什么。而且，你知道，甚至可能是一个对你说了非常有智慧的话的完全陌生的路人。
They could be a grandparent, someone who's role in your life is to teach you and change the course of your life forever. And there's the idea of lifelong soulmates. These people might not, necessarily be your partner. You might not necessarily be friends, but they're people that you know your entire life who support you like no other. Lifelong soulmates are those strong partnerships that stay with us throughout our lives. They might include business partners or family
They could be a grandparent, someone who's role in your life is to teach you and change the course of your life forever. And the idea of lifelong soulmates. These people might not, necessarily be your partner. You might not necessarily be friends, but they're people that you know your entire life who support you like no other. Lifelong soulmates are those strong partnerships that stay with us throughout our lives. They might include business partners or family|||他们可能是祖父母，他们在你生命中的角色是教导你并永远改变你的人生轨迹。还有终身灵魂伴侣的概念。这些人不一定非得是你的伴侣。你们不一定非得是朋友，但他们是你认识了一生、对你的支持无与伦比的人。终身灵魂伴侣是那些陪伴我们一生的强有力的伙伴关系。它们可能包括商业伙伴或家庭
members, sisters, siblings, brothers. Some people are just meant to be there and are meant to be by your side, but some people aren't. I don't think that we should be confusing soulmates with this notion of forever, although that might be what traditional ideas tell us. There's a saying, maybe you know it, I do really love it. And the saying is, a reason, a season, or a lifetime. People aren't meant to be in your life forever. Just because you form a strong bond with someone doesn't mean you need to hang on to them for your whole life.
members, sisters, siblings, brothers. Some people are just meant to be there and are meant to be by your side, but some people aren't. I don't think that we should be confusing soulmates with this notion of forever, although that might be what traditional ideas tell us. There's a saying, maybe you know it, I do really love it. And the saying is, a reason, a season, or a lifetime. People aren't meant to be in your life forever. Just because you form a strong bond with someone doesn't mean you need to hang on to them for your whole life.|||成员、姐妹、手足、兄弟。有些人注定要在那里，注定要在你身边，但有些人则不然。我不认为我们应该将灵魂伴侣与这种“永远”的概念混为一谈，尽管这可能是传统观念告诉我们的。有一句俗语，也许你知道，我真的很喜欢它。这句俗语是：一个原因，一段季节，或是一生。人们注定不会永远留在你的生命中。仅仅因为你与某人建立了强有力的纽带，并不意味着你需要用一生去纠缠他们。
Different types of soulmate relationships may last for different amounts of times, maybe days, some years, and some a lifetime. But people sometimes are just passing through, and you're in each other's lives to teach each other something, an important lesson. I think the word soulmate does signifies, does signify kind of a deep and intense bond, but that doesn't mean it means to be forever or it needs to be perfect. And just because it doesn't last for your lifetime doesn't mean it hasn't been valuable, or it's not a true soulmate connection. Okay, so there is a lot to make of this and this notion of destiny and soulmates. Many of the explanations we've kind of slightly touched on so far have all rested on ideas of a higher power or a deep spiritual path, some form of deity that leads us to our person.
Different types of soulmate relationships may last for different amounts of times, maybe days, some years, and some a lifetime. But people sometimes are just passing through, and you're in each other's lives to teach each other something, an important lesson. I think the word soulmate does signifies, does signify kind of a deep and intense bond, but that doesn't mean it needs to be forever or it needs to be perfect. And just because it doesn't last for your lifetime doesn't mean it hasn't been valuable, or it's not a true soulmate connection. Okay, so there is a lot to make of this and this notion of destiny and soulmates. Many of the explanations we've kind of slightly touched on so far have all rested on ideas of a higher power or a deep spiritual path, some form of deity that leads us to our person.|||不同类型的灵魂伴侣关系可能会持续不同的时间，可能是几天、几年，甚至是一生。但人们有时只是过客，你们进入彼此的生活是为了教给对方一些东西，一个重要的人生课程。我认为“灵魂伴侣”这个词确实象征着一种深厚而强烈的纽带，但这并不意味着它需要永远持续或者需要完美无缺。仅仅因为它没有持续你的一生，并不意味着它没有价值，或者它不是真正的灵魂伴侣连接。好吧，关于这一点以及命运和灵魂伴侣的概念，有很多值得理解的地方。到目前为止，我们稍微触及的许多解释都依托于某种更高力量或深层精神路径的观点，即某种形式的神明引导我们找到属于自己的人。
And although I love this idea and it might feel true, there is some other explanations for why we may have that immediate connection with some people but not others. and why this might lead us to confuse someone we've met as being a soulmate, either romantically or otherwise. This is a psychology podcast. So let's talk about some ideas of biology and personality and compatibility that might provide a better explanation for the idea and existence of soulmates, rather than a spiritual perspective. So there have been a lot of theories that certain personality types are more compatible.
And although I love this idea and it might feel true, there is some other explanations for why we may have that immediate connection with some people but not others. and why this might lead us to confuse someone we've met as being a soulmate, either romantically or otherwise. This is a psychology podcast. So let's talk about some ideas of biology and personality and compatibility that might provide a better explanation for the idea and existence of soulmates, rather than a spiritual perspective. So there have been a lot of theories that certain personality types are more compatible.|||尽管我喜欢这个想法，而且它可能感觉是真的，但对于为什么我们可能会与某些人产生即时连接而与其他人没有，以及为什么这可能会导致我们将遇到的某人误认为浪漫的或其他方面的灵魂伴侣，还有其他一些解释。这是一个心理学播客。所以让我们来谈谈生物学、个性和契合度的一些观点，这些观点可能为灵魂伴侣的概念和存在提供更好的解释，而不是从精神的角度。因此，有很多理论认为某些性格类型更契合。
For decades, decades and decades, experts have kind of trying to, to classify the possible different types of personalities in kind of an attempt to understand why everyone is different, yet similar, and why some people get along better than others. I'm sure you might have a co-worker or a friend who, for some reason, they just grind your gears. There's something about them, you can't put your finger on it, but you just don't get along. Whereas there are other people who it's like, they could do no harm. Nothing they do pisses you off. They are like perfectly suited to you. So I don't know if you've heard about this, but this is called the Myers-Briggs type indicator. And it's one of those tools we were just talking about that's been developed to
For decades, decades and decades, experts have kind of trying to, to classify the possible different types of personalities in kind of an attempt to understand why everyone is different, yet similar, and why some people get along better than others. I'm sure you might have a co-worker or a friend who, for some reason, they just grind your gears. There's something about them, you can't put your finger on it, but you just don't get along. Whereas there are other people who it's like, they could do no harm. Nothing they do pisses you off. They are like perfectly suited to you. So I don't know if you've heard about this, but this is called the Myers-Briggs type indicator. And it's one of those tools we were just talking about that's been developed to|||几十年来，专家们一直在试图对各种可能存在的不同性格类型进行分类，以此来试图理解为什么每个人都不同却又相似，以及为什么有些人比其他人更能合得来。我敢肯定，你可能有一个同事或朋友，出于某种原因，他们就是让你感到很不舒服。他们身上有些地方，你说不上来是什么，但你们就是合不来。然而，另一些人就像是他们绝对不会做什么坏事一样。他们做的事都不会惹恼你。他们就像是完全适合你的人。所以我不知道你是否听说过这个，这被称为迈尔斯-布里格斯性格分类法。它是我们刚刚讨论过的那些旨在
identify personality types and to identify compatibility. I'm going to put this out here. I know a lot of people do their MBTI or their personality type, but it's not particularly evidence-based, and its validity is often kind of question. But it's a really, really interesting kind of experiment to really think about the traits that define you. And if you have heard of Myers-Briggs, it essentially kind of gives you an idea of where you stand on a spectrum of traits. So there's four main kind of letters or comparisons within this personality type. So are you extroverted or are you introverted?
identify personality types and to identify compatibility. I'm going to put this out here. I know a lot of people do their MBTI or their personality type, but it's not particularly evidence-based, and its validity is often kind of question. But it's a really, really interesting kind of experiment to really think about the traits that define you. And if you have heard of Myers-Briggs, it essentially kind of gives you an idea of where you stand on a spectrum of traits. So there's four main kind of letters or comparisons within this personality type. So are you extroverted or are you introverted?|||识别性格类型和识别契合度而开发的工具之一。我要在这里说明这一点。我知道很多人都会测试他们的MBTI或性格类型，但它并不是特别基于证据，其有效性也经常受到质疑。但这是一个非常非常有趣的实验，能让你真正思考那些定义你的特质。如果你听说过迈尔斯-布里格斯，它基本上能让你对自己在特质光谱上所处的位置有个概念。所以在这种性格类型中有四个主要的字母或比较。那么，你是外向的还是内向的？
Do you sense or do you intuit? Are you thinking or are you a feeling person? And do you judge or do you simply perceive? And if you want to do it, it's free, it's online, it's very interesting. and it's based on these personality theories of Carl Jung, and he kind of proposed this system of personality types based on your attitudes around these four kind of equations and how you feel in these situations,
Do you sense or do you intuit? Are you thinking or are you a feeling person? And do you judge or do you simply perceive? And if you want to do it, it's free, it's online, it's very interesting. and it's based on these personality theories of Carl Jung, and he kind of proposed this system of personality types based on your attitudes around these four kind of equations and how you feel in these situations,|||你是靠感官还是靠直觉？你是理性思考型还是感性感觉型？你是倾向于判断还是仅仅去感知？如果你想做这个测试，它是免费的，在网上就能找到，非常有趣。它基于卡尔·荣格的这些个性理论，他根据你对这四种方程式的态度以及你在这些情况下的感受，提出了这个性格类型系统，
whether you are in a situation and you judge what people are doing or you simply perceive it, whether you react with your heart or your brain, these kind of attitudes and these reactions, they are the basis of your personality, which is a distinctive kind of combination of thoughts emotions and experiences that make you who you are. It's unique and complex and it does change and adapt to circumstances, but there are some people who possess a similar personality or compatible traits and it means that you're better able to connect and share beliefs and attitudes with them
whether you are in a situation and you judge what people are doing or you simply perceive it, whether you react with your heart or your brain, these kind of attitudes and these reactions, they are the basis of your personality, which is a distinctive kind of combination of thoughts emotions and experiences that make you who you are. It's unique and complex and it does change and adapt to circumstances, but there are some people who possess a similar personality or compatible traits and it means that you're better able to connect and share beliefs and attitudes with them|||无论你是在某种情境下去判断别人的做法，还是仅仅去感知它，无论你是用心还是用大脑去做出反应，这些态度和这些反应，它们都是你个性的基础。个性是思想、情感和经历的独特组合，造就了独一无二的你。它是独特而复杂的，确实会随环境而改变和适应，但有些人拥有相似的性格或契合的特质，这意味着你能够更好地与他们建立连接，分享信仰和态度，
and you see the world the same way. Compatibility of, you know, obviously falls across a spectrum and it may be that those we share a lot in common with on a personal. and trait level are people we come to see as soulmates, not because of some divine connection, but because of something a lot simpler, which is that we are similar. We are similar. Our personalities gel really well. They might also be feeling. They might also be very intuitive. They might also be extroverted. And because you see the world similarly, you're able to connect and you're able to discuss and be vulnerable with each other. Particularly romantic compatibility, it depends on a lot of factors and circumstances, and this is just one of many ways to look at it.
and you see the world the same way. Compatibility of, you know, obviously falls across a spectrum and it may be that those we share a lot in common with on a personal. and trait level are people we come to see as soulmates, not because of some divine connection, but because of something a lot simpler, which is that we are similar. We are similar. Our personalities gel really well. They might also be feeling. They might also be very intuitive. They might also be extroverted. And because you see the world similarly, you're able to connect and you're able to discuss and be vulnerable with each other. Particularly romantic compatibility, it depends on a lot of factors and circumstances, and this is just one of many ways to look at it.|||并且你们以同样的方式看待世界。你知道，契合度显然存在于一个光谱上，可能正是那些我们在个人和特质层面上有很多共同点的人，最终被我们视为灵魂伴侣，这不是因为某种神圣的连接，而是因为更简单的事情，那就是我们很相似。我们很相似。我们的性格非常合拍。他们可能也是感性型的。他们可能也很有直觉。他们也可能是外向的。正因为你们对世界的看法相似，你们才能够建立连接，能够互相探讨并展露脆弱。特别是浪漫的契合度，它取决于许多因素和环境，这只是看待该问题众多方法中的一种。
But I also think that compatibility doesn't just hinge on this inventory of personality traits. It's not something that you just have. You can also work to be more compatible. It's a process. And obviously our personality changes over the course of our lifetime as things happen, as events happen to us, as we grow, as we mature. So I think that compatibility, it's a disposition and it's an attitude. and it can be worked on and you can come to see things the way others see it and you can come to share a similar outlook. Okay, we talked about personality and compatibility as an explanation for
但我同时认为，契合度并不仅仅取决于这份性格特征清单。它不是某种你天生就有的东西。你也可以通过努力来变得更加契合。这是一个过程。显然，随着事情的发生、事件的降临、我们的成长以及成熟，我们的个性在一生中也会发生变化。因此我认为，契合度是一种性格倾向，也是一种态度，它是可以通过努力来改善的，你可以学会用别人的视角去看待事物，并形成相似的价值观。好了，我们讨论了将性格和契合度作为解释
this idea of soulmates. But what about physical reactions? I think biology, as simple as it sounds, can really explain this deep sensation of having met your twin flame. So another explanation for that unconscious pull and energy we might feel towards someone who we might perceive as a soulmate. It comes from activity within our nervous system and within our hormones and within our brain. Sometimes it's difficult to distinguish what is lost and what is love, particularly when we're talking about someone who we feel a soul connection to. There are just some people we find really attractive and more allure. and the resulting reactions in our body, they're often controlled by instinctual patterns such as
灵魂伴侣这一概念的原因。那么生理反应呢？我认为生物学，听起来很简单，却能很好地解释这种遇到双生火焰的深刻感觉。因此，对于我们对可能被视为灵魂伴侣的人所产生的无意识吸引力和能量，还有另一种解释。它来自于我们神经系统、荷尔蒙以及大脑内部的活动。有时很难分清什么是迷恋，什么是爱，尤其是当我们谈论一个让我们感到灵魂相连的人时。总有一些人会让我们觉得格外有吸引力，充满魅力，而我们身体产生的反应，通常是由本能模式控制的，比如
our libido that explains why we feel deep chemistry with someone. It might just come from attraction. So a likely cause behind this kind of intense soulmate reaction or this infatuation are the chemical reactions that take place in your brain when you're aroused and when you see something that you like. So when you see someone you're attracted to, there are a couple of things that happen in your brain. So firstly, this is a hormone. It's called P-E-A or phenolatolin. It's a natural hormone that's emitted by your body and it speeds up the communication between your nerve cells and triggers the release of dopamine. Our favorite happy hormone, dopamine is the hormone and the neurotransmitter behind feelings of bliss and joy and ecstasy. At the same time, when we are
我们的性欲，这就解释了为什么我们会对某人产生强烈的化学反应。它可能仅仅源于吸引力。因此，这种强烈的灵魂伴侣反应或痴迷背后的一个可能原因，就是当你被唤醒、看到喜欢的事物时，大脑中发生的化学反应。所以，当你看到一个让你心动的人时，你的大脑会发生几件有趣的事情。首先，这是一种荷尔蒙，叫做PEA（苯乙胺）。它是你身体自然分泌的一种荷尔蒙，能够加速神经细胞之间的信息传递，并触发多巴胺的释放。我们最喜欢的快乐荷尔蒙——多巴胺，是带来极乐、快乐和狂喜体验的荷尔蒙和神经递质。与此同时，当我们
attracted to someone, our body releases norapinephrine, which is an arousal or stress hormone that consequently stimulates the production of adrenaline. So combined, these three chemicals, they act almost as an amphetamine and they elevate our energy levels and our mood. And the effects of these chemicals usually can last up to, you know, six months to three years if we're continuing to stay on that high. And of course, if you're not around them all the time, those hormones are released every time you see them. So you're kind of a chasing this high. And it might be that the people we consider our soulmates, especially on a romantic level, are really only in our life because of the physical and biological reactions that their physical appearance or their way of making
被某人吸引时，我们的身体会释放去甲肾上腺素，这是一种唤醒或压力荷尔蒙，它反过来会刺激肾上腺素的产生。因此，这三种化学物质结合在一起，几乎就像安非他命一样，会提升我们的精力和情绪。如果我们继续保持这种兴奋状态，这些化学物质的效果通常可以持续长达六个月到三年。当然，如果你不是一直和他们在一起，每当你看到他们时，这些荷尔蒙就会释放出来。所以你有点像是在追寻这种高潮感。也许我们认为是灵魂伴侣的人，特别是在浪漫层面上的灵魂伴侣，之所以出现在我们的生命中，仅仅是因为他们的外表或他们让我们
us feel creates in our bodies. There are some other theories I want to talk to. One that's really popular and I'm sure we see a lot in the media. If you're on TikTok, you might see this a lot. It's become a bit of psychrobble. It's called love bombing. Love bombing is a pretty known, almost narcissistic, controlling action that partners often use to cause us to fall deeply in love with them or to be deeply attracted and infatuated with them. Love bombing involves the repeated and consistent giving of gifts, giving of attention, giving of love and of love and of services for a brief period of time until we're hooked on another person, and then reality kind of hits. It could be that if you feel you've met your soulmate, maybe sit back and think about
感觉良好的方式在我们的身体中引发了物理和生物学反应。我还想聊聊其他一些理论。其中一个非常受欢迎，我确信我们在媒体上经常看到。如果你刷TikTok，你可能会经常看到它。它已经变成了一种心理学上的流行词，叫做“爱情轰炸”。爱情轰炸是一种相当知名、近乎自恋且具有控制欲的行为，伴侣们经常用它来让我们深深爱上他们，或者对他们产生深深的吸引和痴迷。爱情轰炸包括在短时间内重复且持续地赠送礼物、给予关注、表达爱意、提供关怀和各种服务，直到我们对这个人上瘾，然后现实就会猛然袭来。如果你觉得自己遇到了灵魂伴侣，不妨坐下来想一想
whether you're being love-bombed, and the reactions that's creating that excitement and that attention is really why you feel a deep connection and why you feel deep passion and deep energy. There's also models of addiction that explain ideas of twin flames and soulmates. Like I said, when we're attracted to someone, the way that that feeling kind of reacts and is created in our body is through the release of dopamine. Dopamine is also associated with a lot of addictive practices like gambling and drug addiction and alcohol addiction. It could be that the release and the varied release of dopamine by this person is causing you to become addicted to them because they are a source of real joy and pleasure and bliss. I think also it's worth considering
你是否正在遭受爱情轰炸，而那种产生兴奋感和关注的反应，才是你感到深度连接、深度激情和巨大能量的真正原因。还有一些成瘾模型可以解释双生火焰和灵魂伴侣的概念。正如我所说，当我们被某人吸引时，这种感觉在体内的反应和产生方式是通过释放多巴胺来实现的。多巴胺也与许多成瘾行为有关，比如赌博、药物成瘾和酒精成瘾。这个人释放多巴胺的方式可能让你对他们产生了依赖，因为他们是你真正快乐、愉悦和极乐的源泉。我认为同样值得探讨的是
alternative models. Not everyone believes in soulmates and that's completely valid. It does have a lot of spiritual connotations, you know, the idea of a soul and of a twin flame of someone that you're divinely in and you're meant to meet them and they're meant to be in your life. But there are some other perspectives. I have friends who I really admire and I really agree with them when they tell me that relationships aren't meant to be divine spiritual things. They aren't meant to be divine spiritual things. They to be easy. They aren't meant to be instant, but they take effort and they require work. And the person who you love the most might not necessarily be the best partner for you. The person who you believe is your twin flame and who you connect with on that really deep level maybe isn't who you should
其他的替代模型。并不是每个人都相信灵魂伴侣，这完全可以理解。它确实带有很多精神层面的内涵，你知道的，灵魂和双生火焰的概念——即某人是你命中注定、注定要相遇并注定要出现在你生命中的人。但也有一些其他的视角。我有一些非常钦佩的朋友，他们告诉我关系并非注定是神圣的精神事物时，我非常赞同他们的观点。它们并非注定是神圣的精神连接，它们本该是轻松的。它们不是瞬间形成的，而是需要付出努力和经营。那个你最爱的人，未必就是最适合你的伴侣。那个你认为是双生火焰、与你在极深层次上产生共鸣的人，也许并不是你应该
end up with. It's the person who matches you the best, who suits your personality the best, who shares the similar values as you do, who would be a good partner because you know that you're going to work well together even after that initial spark may have faded. Well, everyone, I hope you enjoyed this brief synthesis around some of the psychology behind twin flames and the idea that we might have a soulmate. I think regardless of what you believe, it does feel amazing when you connect with someone really deeply, whether they are someone you're romantically interested in or a friend or even a sibling or a parent, someone who you feel this deep, intuitive relationship with.
最终走到一起的人。真正适合你的是那个与你最契合、性格最相配、价值观与你相似的人，他会是一个好伴侣，因为你知道即使最初的火花消逝后，你们也能很好地相处。好了，各位，希望大家喜欢这篇关于双生火焰背后的一些心理学原理以及我们可能拥有灵魂伴侣这一概念的简短总结。我认为无论你信仰什么，当你与某人建立起深层次的连接时，这种感觉真的很奇妙，无论对方是你的浪漫心仪对象、朋友，还是父母兄弟，那种让你感到深刻、直觉般联系的人。
So if that's what you're after, go for it. I think some of the other theories that we discussed are really interesting about where that could lead us. If we believe that there is one love that is destined to be ours, it might result in you giving up on something that could be really great before you've really tried it out because you have these deal breakers, because you have this notion and belief in love. I'm not telling you to settle, but it is, I think, some research to kind of take in and to apply to your own perspective and attitude towards love.
所以，如果这就是你所追求的，那就去追求吧。我认为我们讨论过的一些其他理论非常有趣，它们可能会把我们引向何方。如果我们相信这世上有一份命中注定的真爱，它可能会导致你在真正尝试之前就放弃一段本可能非常美好的感情，因为你有着这些绝对不妥协的底线，因为你对爱有着这种刻板的观念和信念。我不是在劝你将就，但我认为，这些研究可以用来审视和调整你对待爱的态度与视角。
It's also worth considering some of those other theories, those biological theories, love bombing, addiction, the right time, putting work into your relationships, all in all, an incredibly interesting topic, and one that I had a lot of fun researching. Like I always say when I end these episodes, if this resonated with you, if you enjoy this content, and if you feel called to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple or Spotify. It really helps the podcast grow, and we have so many new listeners at the moment. Hello to you all, and to all of you who've reached out to me. It is just insane to me. I really, I just like can't fathes.
同时，我们也值得去思考其他的一些理论，比如生物学理论、爱情轰炸、成瘾机制、正确的时间、经营你的感情等等。总之，这是一个极其有趣的话题，我在研究它的时候也乐在其中。就像我在每期节目结束时常说的那样，如果这引起了你的共鸣，如果你喜欢这个内容，并且愿意这样做，请随时在Apple Podcasts或Spotify上留下五星好评。这真的对播客的成长很有帮助，目前我们有非常多的新听众。大家好，向所有联系过我的听友问好。这对我来说简直太疯狂了。我真的，我简直无法想象
them how many people want to listen to my voice. I don't even know. It's yeah, I'm kind of stumbling over my words a little bit but I feel really, really grateful. So thank you for all of your support. It really is just insane. It blows my mind and I really appreciate it. Follow us on Instagram. It's where I get a lot of my topic ideas from. So if you have something that we haven't talked about before that you think would be a really good match with some of these psychological explanations, And shoot it, shoot it to me. Send it to me. I will read it and I will let you know what I think. And hopefully we'll be able to integrate it into a future episode. But thank you so much for listening. Enjoy your lovely beautiful weeks, your weekends, wherever you are in the world.
竟然有这么多人想听我的声音。我甚至不知道该说什么了。是的，我说话有点结巴，但我内心真的、真的很感激。谢谢大家所有的支持。这真的是太疯狂了。这完全超出了我的想象，我非常感激。请在Instagram上关注我们，我很多话题灵感都是从那里来的。所以，如果你有什么我们还没讨论过、但你认为非常适合融入这些心理学解释的话题，那就发给我，发给我吧。我会阅读它，并告诉你我的想法。希望我们能把它融入到未来的节目中。非常感谢大家的收听。无论你身在世界何处，祝你拥有美好的一周和愉快的周末。
And I will see you next week for another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere. but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast,
我们下周的节目再见。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主播卡尔·加姆斯。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方绝对无法安全展开的坦诚对话。但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的专业执照人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲？它向世界释放出一种信号：你可不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你具备这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts上收听《艰难抉择》，
or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
或者在任何你收听播客的地方。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让人生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，这份特定的测试报告是你伪造了两次，对吗？我伪造过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·吉勒斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。